I want to talk to you about something
I've been thinking a lot about and that
relates to Donald Trump filling his
cabinet with former members of the
military there's at least four retired
generals that may be in the mix for
prominent roles in Donald Trump's
administration we have retired Marine
general Jim mattis who has been selected
already for defense secretary that is
notable because there's this
long-standing tradition where you don't
name a retired military leader to serve
as defense secretary period and in
particular mattis is going to require
Congress to grant a waiver that it
previously gave to world war ii veteran
george marshall who held the position of
Secretary of Defense under President
Harry Truman active or former military
members and must be out of active duty
for seven years before serving as
Secretary of Defense mattis has only be
out I've been out for three so that will
require a special waiver from Congress
that's number one we also know about
retired Army Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn in the position of Donald Trump's
national security adviser cuckoo for
cocoa puffs guys out of his mind we've
talked about that already we know that
Donald Trump is considering retired
general John Kelly as Homeland Security
Secretary we know that Donald Trump met
a few days ago with retired Rear Admiral
Jay Cohen a former senior homeland
security official and additionally we
spoke about this a little bit yesterday
retired four-star Army General David
Petraeus is in the mix as a possible
Secretary of State so there's concern
about the military heavy weight of
trumps cabinet and advisors from
lawmakers from diplomats from former
national security officials and the
general concern is sort of obvious to
many former military in the president's
cabinet and in his ear makes the
president overly influenced by a
military perspective people who are more
likely to see based on their careers in
the military the military as the
solution to problems rather than
diplomacy and if you have a president
with lots of foreign policy and national
security experience from the civilian
world
you don't worry that much because you
have that as a counterbalance to the
military perspective that you will get
from your cabinet or advisors but
remember Pat that Trump has no
experience at all so you have someone
with no experience in foreign policy
diplomacy national security and the
voices that he will be having in his ear
so to speak who will be
disproportionately military voices for
his presidency that is a real concern
yeah in the United States has even
warned other countries against putting
too many military leaders in the in
positions of power absolutely they're
going to be overly aggressive
and the other concern too is that some
of these military leaders may have
expertise in the Middle East but not so
much diplomatic relationships in Europe
Asia Africa etc increasingly important
areas where we are going that is
basically declaring trade war on China
and some of our other primary trading
partners and let me remind you that
Trump and his base claim to be about the
Constitution and an important
constitutional premise is civilian
control of the government not military
control and I know that some some
trumpets will hear this and they'll say
David when your former military you are
a civilian but that is a technicality
what I'm talking about is the big
picture that those who are career
military are going to have a very
different view as pat says on foreign
and national security policy than those
who come from the civilian world in
terms of their careers and I want to put
up a quote for you from Gordon Adams
who's a former White House official and
professor at American University who
said it isn't about personalities the
problem here is structural a president
who doesn't know much about foreign
policy and a vice president who doesn't
know much about foreign policy are
surrounding themselves with people who
served in uniform it runs counter to the
American tradition of civilian control
do you want a big portion of your
national security and defense and
foreign policy advisers coming from the
less than 1% that has served in the
military that is an incredibly narrow
scope of experience and this is totally
separate from the specifics of these
particular former military people I've
already told you
the crazy ideas of Michael Flynn are
there any silver linings the theme of
the next four years can we find a silver
lining here well one silver lining is
that Trump expressed quote surprise that
madis who is a a generally tough-talking
guy actually talked him against the use
of torture and Trump as Trump told the
New York Times I said what do you think
of waterboarding
madis said I've never found it useful
I've always found give me a pack of
cigarettes and a couple of beers and I
do better with that than I do with
torture is that a possible silver lining
that mattes seems to at least recognize
the pragmatic reality that torture isn't
effective well I mean Trump is easily
convinced it seems and you know just go
along with the last person in the room
so in that case yes it is if Trump
doesn't hire them
how will he teach them remember Trump
said during the election that he knows
more than the general so maybe this is
all a ploy just to hire all of these
generals and then teach them really
important to keep a close eye on Donald
Trump's relationship to the military we
don't want to go in the direction of
many of the countries that make it a
habit to regularly have current and
former military running the entire
country that that is the seed of
autocracy and a lot of other Assis that
many in our audience are probably
increasingly fearful of I've talked
about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is Zipcar which gets you
a car when you want it when you need it
they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your zip
card each car share member reduces their
personal co2 emissions by between 1100
and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
comm slash david support our show
Douce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars
sign up at join Zipcar calm slash David